>> Laura: LAURA INGRAHAM, THIS
IS THE INGRAM ANGLE FROM
WASHINGTON.
LAST NIGHT WE EXPLAIN IDEA OBAMA
INTEL JIM CLAPPER WAS ANGRY
ABOUT ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR
CONFIRMING THAT THE TRUMP AM
PAIR HAD, INDEED, BEEN SPIED
UPON.
HE WASN'T THE ONLY ONE.
AND TONIGHT IS JIM COMEY'S TURN
IN THE BARREL.
PLUS THE DEMOCRAT CONGRESSIONAL
HEARING WERE A FARCE FROM
BEGINNING TO END, ALL OF THE
EMBARRASSING MOMENTS YOU KNOW
YOU MISSED THEM, AND THE HI
LIARIOUS CLAPBACKS COMING UP.
WHAT'S BEHIND THE RELIGIOUS WAR
AGAINST VICE PRESIDENT PENCE?
DON'T GET IT.
AND SCREWY LOUIS FARRAKHAN FOR
GET WHAT FUNERAL HE WAS
ATENTING.
A HOLY EDITION OF "FRIDAY
FOLLIES."
IN "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE," STORIES
YOU MAY HAVE MISSED.
FIRST WE HIT IMMIGRATION.
THE LEFT HAS A VERY INTERESTING
WAY OF APPROACHING THIS ISSUE.
IT'S NOT AN EMERGENCY, IS IT,
WHEN 100,000 PEOPLE ARE POURING
ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
BUT WHEN IT'S REPORTED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CONSIDERING
BUSSING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
DETAENEES TO SANCTUARY CITIES
THE DEMOCRATS FREAK OUT.
THE PRESIDENT UMPED THE ANTE
TODAY.
>> President Trump: WE CAN GIVE
THEM A LOT, WE CAN GIVE THEM AN
UNLIMITED SUPPLY.
AND LET'S SEE IF THEY'RE SO
HAPPY, THEY SAY WE HAVE OPEN
ARMS, THEY'RE ALWAYS SAYING THEY
HAVE OPEN ARMS.
LET'S SEE IF THEY HAVE OPEN
ARMS.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT MAY HAVE
LEGAL STANDING TO MAKE GOOD ON
THE THREAT.
AND LOOK THE HOW THE DEMOCRATS
ARE SWARMING NOW.
NANCY PELOSI SAID THE EXTENT OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION CYNICISM AND
CRUELTY CANNOT BE OVERSTATED.
BUT, WAIT, WAIT A SECOND,
SHOULDN'T SHE AND HER OTHER
CALIFORNIA POLITICIANS, ONES ALL
FOR OPEN BORDERS, SHOULDN'T THEY
BE THRILLED?
THEY ARE THE ONES, AFTER ALL,
WHO HAVE SAID THIS ABOUT
SANCTUARY CITIES.
>> IN OUR SANCTUARY CITIES OUR
PEOPLE ARE NOT DISOBEYING THE
LAW.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF GIVING
SANCTUARY TO SOME ONE WHO HAS,
IS GUILTY OF A CRIME.
>> THE FACT IS SANCTUARY CITIES
KEEP PEOPLE SAFER, HEALTHIER,
AND KEEP PEOPLE EDUCATED.
>> Laura: I MEAN, THAT'S A
COMMERCIAL FOR SANCTUARY CITIES.
TAKE THEM IN, BRING THEM IN,
WELCOME THEM IN.
BUT IT'S NOT SO SIMPLE, IS IT?
CONSIDER THIS HORRIFIC CRIME IN
THE SANCTUARY CITY OF JERSEY
CITY.
ILLEGAL ALIEN IS CHARGED IN THE
MARCH 24 RAPE AND MURDER OF
JOGGER CARE ON LIEN A CANO.
JORGE RIOS WAS DEPORTED TWO
TIMES FROM THE UNITED STATES
BEFORE RETURNING ILLEGALLY A
THIRD TIME.
HE SHE WORKED AS A NANNY,
INCREDIBLE WOMAN, OF STRONG
FAITH AND A BEAUTIFUL, GIVING
HEART.
BUT THE LEFT DOESN'T ACKNOWLEDGE
THESE AMERICAN TRAGEDIES,
THEY'RE TOO BUSY TRYING TO
DEMONIZE TOUCH TRUMP ON THIS AND
SCORE POLITICAL POINTS.
BRINGS US TO OUR NEXT STORY.
THIS WEEK DEMOCRATS CONTINUED
FLAILING IN THE WAKE OF BOB
MUELLER'S NO COLLUSION FINDING.
I THINK THEY'RE BEYOND DESPERATE
TO REGAIN POLITICAL FOOTING
AFTER TWO YEARS OF LEVELLING
DEFAMATORY AND FALSE ACCUSATIONS
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
REMEMBER HE WAS BASICALLY
SPOONING WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
BUT THEY QUICKLY FOUND A NEW
TARGET, ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
BARR.
>> HIS CREDIBILITY WILL BE
ABSOLUTELY SHREDDED IF HE FAILS
TO RETRACT THIS ASSERTION.
>> HE LOST WHATEVER CREDIBILITY
HE MAY HAVE HAD.
>> CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
OF OUR COUNTRY IS GOING OFF THE
RAILS.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FEELS
IT'S HIS JOB TO DO THE
PRESIDENT'S BIDDING.
>> Laura: NOW, WATCHING BARR AT
THE HEARINGS THIS WEEK FLICK OFF
ALL OF THEIR INSIPID COMMENTS
AND INQUIRIES, ONE BY ONE, I
HAVE TO SAY I WATCHED EVERY
MINUTE OF ALL OF THE HEARINGS
AND WITH BARR IT WAS BETTER THAN
ANYTHING ON NETFLIX.
THE MEDIA, THOUGH, JOINED THE
LIBERAL BARR CRAWL, LOOKING FOR
ANY BUZZ THEY COULD GET.
>> THIS GUY IS ON A TIGHTROPE,
ON ONE SIDE HE WANTS TO LEAN ONE
WAY TO MAKE SURE TRUMP KEEPS HEM
IN A JOB AND DON'T LOOK LIKE AN
ASS.
>> YOU CAN ALMOST SEE HIS MIND,
BARR GOING, OKAY, HOW DO I
ANSWER THIS QUESTION SO TRUMP
DOESN'T FEET AT ME.
-- TWEET AT ME.
SO I KEEP MY JOB.
BUT STILL NOT MAKE A JACK ASS
OUT OF MYSELF, FOR A LIE.
>> THAT'S TOUGH.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW WHAT'S TOUGH?
THIS OBVIOUS THOUGHT, AFRAID TO
LOSE HIS JOB?
YOU MEAN GO BACK TO A
COMFORTABLE NO STRESS RETIREMENT
AND ENJOY HIS GRAND KIDS?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
WHY WOULD BILL BARR DO SOMETHING
UNETHICAL TODAY IN ORDER TO SAVE
A JOB HE ALREADY HAD 30 YEARS
AGO?
NEWS FLASH, HE DOESN'T NEED TO
BUILD HIS RESUME, KIDS.
A MOMENT THAT SENT SHIVERS DOWN
THE SPINES OF THE FORMER OBAMA
DEEP STATERS WAS THIS ONE.
>> I THINK SPYING ON A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN IS A BIG DEAL.
>> YES, I THINK SPYING DID OCCUR
AND I'M NOT SUGGESTING IT WASN'T
ADEQUATELY PREDICATED BUT I NEED
EXPLORE THAT.
>> Laura: I WONDER HOW JIM COMEY
FELT UPON HEARING THAT SPYING
REFERENCE.
>> LOOK, THIS IS TERRIBLE.
IT MAKES ME MILDLY NAUSEOUS TO
THINK WE MIGHT HAVE HAD IMPACT
ON THE ELECTION.
>> Laura: WELL, IT TURNS OUT THE
FORMER SPOOK HAD SOMETHING TO
HIDE, PRACTICED THE ART OF
DEFLECTION.
AND THEN THEY PLAY WORD GAMES.
>> SPYING IS A TERM I NEVER
LIKED, I NEVER LIKED THAT TERM
APPLIED TO ME.
IT HAS A BAD CONNOTATION.
IT'S PEJORATIVE TERM.
>> I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT SPYING ON
THE CAMPAIGN.
THE FBI AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CONDUCT KOEMPT-ORDERED
ELECTRONIC SURVEILLANCE.
I HAVE NEVER THOUGHT OF THAT AS
SPYING.
>> Laura: LET ME GET IT
STRAIGHT, CLAPPER AND COMEY, JIM
SQUARED WHAT WE CALL THEM HERE,
WERE THE GUYS DETERMINED TO GET
SOMETHING ON PRESIDENT TRUMP
THROUGH SURVEILLANCE AND LEAKING
TO THE MEDIA.
BUT NOW THEY'RE SPENDING THEIR
TIME QUIBBLING WITH THE TERM
SPYING?
NOW, THIS CONCERN, THIS IS ALL
PHONY, OVER SEMANTICS REEKS OF
DESPERATION.
I THINK THE REAL FEAR IS THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR IS
EXTREMELY SERIOUS, VERY
JUDICIOUS, EXTREMELY
PROFESSIONAL, AND HE'S ON THE
CASE.
THEY ALSO KNOW THAT THE